in terms of heart and a giri's notion of
corrupt or identity Darian love um
there's that again the images I use are
often you know very much about kind of
you know you sort of you topic political
and social fantasy and a bunch of
different levels and and there are very
much images that that elicit or a sort
of beckon or or or inspire you know like
like a sense of you know collective
identity notions of freedom spaces of
possibility and in a way like these it
actually does exactly the opposite I
mean these become i think that the sort
of the perverse underbelly or the kind
of that sort of the other inscription of
these terms all the way from you know
the kind of imperialist project of
manifest destiny in the 19th century to
the fascism of the 30s and 40s and in
contemporary the contemporary rhetoric
of American democracy and freedom
you